Governor Chris Christie former Governor
Christie of New Jersey is with us
governor you know I understand Mike
Tobin just interviewed a guy extremely
articulate and passionate about how he
feels some guy that has served this
country and I see the crowds there and I
saw this guy was armed and I think about
all the people in the city and I think
about what's happening can you explain
the process what the president's
expedited investigation means in the
hopes that good people won't get hurt in
in these protests or any innocent people
hurt
absolutely Sean what the president will
now have done his director ray will put
a flood of FBI agents both from their
field office in Minneapolis and from the
headquarters in Washington DC to
interview anyone who is in that crowd
anyone in the area attempt to interview
the officers involved themselves that
may or may not permit themselves me
interview and if they've already
retained lawyers which I suspect they
have look at all the forensic evidence
and then immediately go to the US
attorney in Minnesota who has already
assigned I'm confident assistant US
attorneys to work with the FBI on this
case and to get it in front of a grand
jury as quickly as possible and that's
what they're going to be doing right now
and the only way to make that happen
quickly is to throw a lot of resources
at it I'm confident that attorney
general Barr is instructed the US
Attorney to do that when it comes to
prosecutors and that director Ray has
done it when it applies to agents you
know and and this is important to note
to you have you know worked in varying
forms of being in charge of law
enforcement I think it's important for
people to understand I've talked a lot
the last three years about the 1% of
people that abused their power and were
corrupt and we see the damage of 1% that
has not been my experience in law
enforcement siapa the 99 percent that do
their job and protect and serve and I
know at moments like this people forget
that part
but it looks also to where's the
training of these guys how do you not
know the neck is that sensitive and
inched on where is the the officers that
are standing near this guy
who are willing to stand up and stop him
you know that's the problem too
now the you know this guy doing what he
done is it awful act but it's just as
awful to be there as an officer here
akai sake he cannot breathe while he's
handcuffed on the ground and to not
intervene and stop your fellow officers
from doing it your obligation to the law
applies not just to the citizens that
you are that you're protecting every day
it applies to making sure that law is
enforced against your colleagues in the
police department all right governor
thank you for being with us we
appreciate it